uh let's see where we want to go next
oh i don't know
um what about maybe
dave from kansas city dave you're on the
air
can you hear me yes i can
alrighty then uh first time caller um
i'm going to be as brief as i can it is
kind of a loaded question um
basically my politics lean the same as
you so there's no um head-to-head here
if you will uh but i've not been keeping
the best update on the situation this is
regarding the supreme court leak okay um
basically
you said something recently that kind of
made me raise an eyebrow and i've seen
other people do it as well so here we go
initially it was stated by those on the
right that the left-wing person did it
to try to
pressure change from the leaked opinion
yep um but later i heard that uh the
reddit the rhetoric changed
um to be likely
a person on the right putting pressure
on the judges to keep their vote the
reason this raised an eyebrow for me was
because
you know if you assume the least
amount of information out of all these
using occam's razor these are the same
amount of assumptions
what am i missing from the quote-unquote
likely yeah nature
that's a great question so basically
in terms of plausibility
when it comes to the supreme court leak
you can argue in if if you know nothing
and you all you have is motive you could
say well a left winger would have motive
to leak it to try to pressure the
justices who were going to vote to
overturn roe v wade to change their mind
from motive you could also say a
right-winger might have leaked it in
order to try to pressure the justices
planning to overturn roe v wade to stick
with that decision if they suspected
maybe they were going to change so that
you're absolutely right we don't have
more information one way or the other
we have gotten reports from long-time
supreme court reporters including one
from npr whose name i don't remember
offhand who said
based on everyone she's talked to
the consensus within the court is that
it was more likely a right winger so
that's that's the only difference maker
you're correct that we have almost the
same thing on both sides other than a
couple of reports from long-time supreme
court reporters who say the feeling is
it was more likely a right winger we
don't know at this point
okay
yeah it was just something that kind of
i didn't hear that last part the yeah i
think maybe now that i'm thinking about
it i just couldn't find it going through
i only have so much time to go through
all the videos yeah we linked to the
source in the story i did about it we
link to the npr source
okay sounds good i'll check that out all
right thank you so much for the call we
are going to take more calls in a moment
i'm just going to take a very quick
break and then we'll be right back just
hold on and then we'll get to more
people